three dice are rolled simultaneously
what is the probability that their sum
is equal to 9.
each of the dice has six faces so there
will be six times six times six which
equals two sixteen possibilities we now
count Triplets of non-decreasing numbers
that have a sum equal to nine since nine
minus six is equal to three which is
equal to one plus two the smallest two
numbers can be one two and six we then
increase the second number and decrease
the third to get one through five we
then have one four four we then need to
go to two two five and two three four
and finally we have three three we now
need to count the number of Arrangements
of each of these so the first has three
factorial the second is three factorial
the third has a repeated four so it'll
be three factorial over two factorial
same for the fourth finally we have
three factorial and finally we just have
three factorial over three factorial
which is equal to one so we wanna add up
these possibilities which gives us 25
and thus the probability is twenty five
over two sixteen